Daniel blew it what an amazing year
you've had because this time last year
you know this was not going to be the
year that was coming this is amazing I
was just chilling out and then this film
came out Dana Cindy this indie horror
and then you know it's been it's been
life-changing
yeah happened I'm sorry so Oscar
nominated for Best Actor but also the
BAFTAs bien
but you've got to get something you're
nominated Best Actor and rising star
that would be true cruel to give you
nothing I mean in the Apertura David
with a Brit
[Music]
you can go away he had six oh yeah
that's what I mean kind of good attitude
to have David came back he came back I
took about 20 years but he came you
gotta give me something you've had some
practice now with the big sled because
obviously with Golden Globes yeah so who
did you meet at the Golden Globes how
long you got man it's just like before
is awards governor governor's awards and
she was really cool when we just spoke
about stuff it was really nice it was
English cuz these accent was so flawless
and get out and I was like oh my god and
anytime I meet anyone who's English I'm
just immediately like I love London I
miss the two if I met at weapons yeah I
met Denzel at then so and Oprah at the
same time it was what it was this this
segue it was just this leg I don't know
black african-american excellent segue
or blankets I don't know des Eaux came
up to me was that you came talking
English axioms that yeah mate yeah
cheers mate cheers mate cheers me and
I'm like what what's happening how do
you know any was like and anyways he's
worth like the Opera
let's meet oh I just yeah I'm a hugger
so tell you an amazing Graham let us
wear is just premium smell amazing I've
never but when I do I'm gonna hug her
for free at the Golden Globes but she
was too far away
you got inhale deeply such a nice smell
in the room yeah no she was really cool
it was really surreal
[Music]
you